[Aplausos]
[Música]
españa es conocido por ser el país de
julio iglesias del flamenco y de las
altas tasas de desempleo e incluso ahora
cuando europa está saliendo de la crisis
este país mantiene un paro superior al
de irak o albania en otras palabras que
españa no es precisamente un modelo en
lo que a economía se refiere sin embargo
hay una región que se sale de este
patrón
amigos de visual porque hablamos del
país vasco también conocido como euskadi
junto con navarra son las dos regiones
más ricas y prósperas de todo el país en
casi todos los indicadores tanto el país
vasco como navarra suelen estar en la
parte de arriba muy por encima por
cierto de cataluña dicho de otra forma
podríamos decir que estas dos regiones
son algo así como la pequeña alemania
dentro de españa con un sistema político
totalmente distinto al del resto del
país y un tejido empresarial más propio
del norte de europa que del sur
es más en esta zona también existe una
lengua propia el euskera
a diferencia del catalán el euskera no
se parece en nada al castellano
de hecho los lingüistas no son capaces
de ponerse de acuerdo sobre el origen de
esta lengua pero si alguno de los que
nos veis desde latinoamérica se apellida
iñárritu o echevarría poder decir que
tenéis algún ancestro que viene de esta
región pero no sólo eso al igual que
cataluña el país vasco es una región con
un importante movimiento separatista
[Música]
diez años antes de que los políticos
catalanes comenzaran a exigir la
independencia el gobierno vasco también
intentó convertirse en un estado
soberano
efectivamente hablamos del llamado plan
ibarretxe el por aquel entonces
presidente del país vasco o como se le
llama oficialmente el lendakari vasco
juan josé ibarretxe intentó un divorcio
con españa que salió bastante mal pero
de todo eso hablaremos en otro vídeo
de hoy es porque el país vasco y navarra
son las regiones más ricas de españa
porque decimos que tienen un sistema
político tan distinto al del resto del
país hoy vamos a responder a estas
preguntas pero antes vamos a ver un poco
de historia
una herencia medieval mucha gente piensa
que este estatus especial que tiene el
país vasco y navarra el llamado
concierto o convenio económico viene de
la edad media pero en realidad no es así
[Música]
en el año 1200 el antiguo reino de
navarra lo que ahora son las provincias
de álava vizcaya guipúzcoa y la propia
navarra se unió a la corona de castilla
y como condición para esta unión el rey
castellano tuvo que reconocer los
llamados fueros navarros es decir este
reino mantendría un gobierno
independiente con sus propias leyes sus
propios tribunales y sus propios
impuestos por ejemplo ningún ciudadano
navarro podía estar obligado a hacer el
servicio militar
[Música]
los fueros navarros se mantuvieron
prácticamente intactos durante siglos
pero no penséis que se trata de ninguna
anomalía todos los sistemas políticos
feudales o absolutistas tanto en españa
como en francia o reino unido estaban
llenos de
con derechos y leyes especiales sin
embargo la cosa cambió totalmente en el
siglo 19
[Música]
en ese momento es cuando españa se
consolida como un estado moderno y
decide imitar el modelo de la francia de
napoleón es decir un modelo centralista
eso significa que casi todas las leyes
se dictarían desde la capital y se
aplicarían de igual manera por todo el
territorio como os podéis imaginar esto
no les hizo ninguna gracia a los
ciudadanos navarros y vascos de repente
tenían que pagar más impuestos y prestar
servicio militar obligatorio eso explica
que durante el siglo 19 españa tuviera
no una ni dos sino tres guerras civiles
y las llamadas guerras carlistas donde
los partidarios del antiguo régimen
principalmente vascos y navarros
luchaban contra el ejército español así
que en 1876 con las tropas
vasco-navarras derrotadas los foros
fueron abolidos
[Música]
de repente estas cuatro provincias
tenían que seguir la ley que venía de
madrid además tenían que pagar un
porcentaje de los impuestos que recauda
sen al estado central
[Música]
[Aplausos]
en cambio madrid permitió que estas
regiones conservarán un estatus fiscal
especial y hasta concesión es a lo que
llamamos el concierto vasco que como
veis no nació en la edad media sino que
se aprobó como contrapartida tras haber
abolido los fueros
pero la cosa no termina aquí décadas más
tarde en 1939 la dictadura de franco
elimina este concierto económico pero
solo a las dos provincias que no le
apoyaron guipúzcoa y vizcaya como podéis
ver se trata de una historia bastante
tortuosa de guerras y desagravios por
ambos lados estas dos provincias que
habían perdido sus condiciones fiscales
especiales estaban especialmente sólidas
y eso se nota hasta nuestros días donde
un enorme porcentaje de vizcaínos y
guipuzcoanos querrían separarse del
resto de españa'
y esto explica que en los años 70 los
redactores de la nueva constitución
democrática quisieran resarcir a los
ciudadanos vascos y navarros y así es
como volvió el concierto vasco pero esta
vez en una versión moderna
el grupo vasco a todos los que veáis
este vídeo desde españa prestad atención
porque este es uno de los temas y más
confusión general en la política
nacional veréis un ciudadano que viva en
málaga o en valladolid paga la mayor
parte de sus impuestos directamente al
gobierno central por supuesto que hay
algunos tributos especiales que dependen
del lado de la comunidad autónoma pero
la gran mayoría va para la hacienda
nacional después el estado reparte este
dinero entre los diferentes gobiernos
autonómicos según le convenga
estas son las llamadas transferencias
autonómicas que habréis oído mencionar
en los telediarios y por supuesto
algunas regiones suelen salir
beneficiadas de estas transferencias y
otras salen perjudicadas la teoría y
digo la teoría porque esto es bastante
discutible es que las regiones más ricas
ayudan a las más pobres
sin embargo tanto navarra como el país
vasco tienen un sistema distinto en este
caso los gobiernos provinciales son
quienes recaudan casi todos los
impuestos y fijaros bien que he dicho
provinciales es decir un ciudadano que
viva por ejemplo en bilbao no tributan
al gobierno vasco sino a la diputación
provincial de vizcaya y este gobierno
provincial tiene autonomía para poder
hacer cosas como estas
nunca ya cambiará el impuesto de
sociedades para ganar competitividad
recordáis este otro vídeo en el que os
contábamos por qué suiza es tan rico una
de las razones es que en suiza los
diferentes cantones pueden competir
entre ellos por ofrecer mejores
condiciones fiscales pues bien algo
parecido ocurre entre las provincias
vascas y navarras y eso explica que la
tributación en esta región sea un
poquito más baja que en el resto de
españa'
y os preguntaréis entonces estas
diputaciones provinciales no pagan nada
al estado español nada de eso y aquí es
donde entra en escena el llamado cupo
vasco que seguramente habréis visto
muchas veces en los periódicos
[Música]
el cupo vasco es el porcentaje que pagan
estas regiones al gobierno central a
cambio de los servicios comunes de los
que disfrutan por pertenecer a españa
por ejemplo el ejército o las embajadas
o las carreteras
todo eso son cosas que se pagan desde
madrid pero que también disfrutan los
vascos entonces estos tienen que pagar
una parte del coste pero no sólo eso si
por ejemplo un día españa decidiera
aumentar el presupuesto en defensa por
ejemplo este cupo también crecería de
forma proporcional como os podéis
imaginar todo esto es la teoría la
realidad es que el cupo vasco es el
resultado de negociaciones políticas
pero eso ya es otra historia que
trataremos en otro vídeo lo cierto es
que a diferencia de todas las demás
comunidades autónomas el país vasco y
navarra saben exactamente con cuántos
recursos contarán cuánto dinero pagan al
común y con cuánto se quedan
pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
se queda la cosa en principio podría
parecer que el concierto económico es un
sistema bastante justo verdad todo queda
negro sobre blanco en una negociación
pero lo cierto es que el sistema dista
mucho de ser perfecto recordáis que os
decía y el estado central reparte ese
dinero que recauda entre las distintas
comunidades autónomas pues lo cierto es
que tanto navarra como el país vasco
también forman parte de este reparto y
siendo unas regiones tan ricas sería
lógico pensar que aportan más de lo que
reciben verdad pues nada de eso
el país vasco' recibe el doble de
recursos per cápita que madrid cataluña
o andalucía y os preguntaréis cómo es
esto posible
la razón es puramente política como os
decía el nacionalismo vasco es tan
importante como lo puede ser el catalán
y eso significa que en estas comunidades
autónomas tienen sus propios partidos
políticos partidos como por ejemplo el
partido nacionalista vasco que ostenta
el gobierno de su comunidad y que
también tiene una representación en el
parlamento nacional
[Música]
y como ya sabéis cada año el gobierno
central tiene que aprobar los
presupuestos generales en el parlamento
para eso necesita una mayoría absoluta
mayoría que en la mayor parte de los
casos requiere el apoyo de estos
partidos nacionalistas y por supuesto
eso les da una capacidad enorme para
negociar sin embargo sólo un necio diría
que esta es la única razón que explica
la prosperidad del país vasco' para nada
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
la alemania de españa os suena una
empresa que se llama por clic pues si
tenéis una cocina de gas es muy probable
que tengáis alguno de sus productos se
trata del líder mundial de fabricación
de sistemas para evitar accidentes y
fugas de gas y su sede está en ordizia
un pueblo de la provincia de guipúzcoa
y lo mismo ocurre con jm si tenéis una
puerta blindada en vuestra casa es muy
probable que tanto la cerradura como las
llaves estén fabricadas por esta empresa
que está situada en mondragón también en
el país vasco son los llamados líderes
ocultos
pequeñas compañías hiper especializadas
que se han convertido en los referentes
mundiales de su nicho y que arrasan en
el mercado internacional en este otro
vídeo os contábamos que alemania debe
parte de su riqueza a las llamadas
mittelstand
pues bien el modelo económico vasco es
muy similar es más si tenéis la
oportunidad de viajar en carretera por
euskadi veréis que hay fábricas por toda
su geografía de hecho la distribución de
la población del país vasco' frente a lo
que podríamos pensar es bastante
dispersa
por supuesto que hay grandes ciudades
pero la mayoría de la gente vive en
núcleos urbanos de menos de 40 mil
habitantes y la mayoría de estos
municipios tienen su polo empresarial
que da empleo a los lugareños si en el
país vasco' la actividad económica no se
concentra sólo en las grandes ciudades y
os preguntaréis porque euskadi tiene un
tejido empresarial tan homogéneo
pues volvemos al mismo principio de
antes la descentralización al tener
cuatro haciendas distintas con autonomía
para recaudar impuestos y hacer
inversiones existe muchísima más
competencia fiscal que en cualquier otra
parte de españa eso se traduce en que
las inversiones públicas no se
concentran en un lugar concreto sino que
se reparten de forma homogénea
la inversión en start up tendrá una
reducción del 30 por ciento en gipuzkoa
en otras palabras es cierto tanto los
vascos como los navarros juegan con una
enorme ventaja porque reciben dinero
desde el estado central pero ese dinero
se ha invertido de forma mucho más
eficiente que cualquier otra región de
hecho no es casualidad que estas dos
comunidades sean las menos endeudadas de
toda españa y que además apenas hayan
estado salpicadas por los casos de
corrupción que han emponzoñado el resto
del país
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es creéis que
se podrían rescatar algunos elementos
del modelo vasco y navarro para otros
países sería posible aplicar el
concierto vasco a todas las demás
regiones
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribirse a este canal
y gesto completamente gratuito y os
permitirá estar al tanto de todas
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo darte a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto
[Música]